on est à monsieur marc le fur merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
mais on me dit qu'il n'est pas sur le
territoire national ce qui est un peu
surprenant ces périodes compliquées
je souhaite vous alerter sur la pénurie
de carburant qui risquent de gagner tout
le pays
progressivement les stations d'essence
ferme c'est le cas déjà d'un quart
d'entre elles et pour celles qui sont
encore ouvertes
les files d'attentes s'allongent deux
mots dominent les conversations de nos
compatriotes pénurie et chienlit
cette pénurie un pack la vie quotidienne
de nos compatriotes des familles de
celles dé ceux qui veulent aller
travailler
cette pénurie impact déjà la vie de nos
entreprises
elles ne sont pas à l'arrêt mais déjà
ralenti c'est le cas des commerciaux
c'est le cas des transporteurs et cela
risque de s'accentuer du fait de la
grève dans les raffineries
comment cela est il possible alors que
nous sommes en plein état d'urgence
dans ce contexte le propos du président
de la république sur ça va mieux
apparaît déconnecté de la vie des vrais
gens cela apparaît comme quasiment un
propos extraterrestre il ajouta
l'anxiété nos compatriotes qui ont le
sentiment que nos dirigeants vivent dans
un autre monde que le leur notre premier
ministre mais fréquemment en avant la
liberté de manifester ici avec mon
groupe je voudrais mettre en avant la
liberté de circuler d'aller et venir la
liberté d'aller à son travail
la liberté d'en revenir alors monsieur
le premier ministre
quand est-ce que sa liberté cette
liberté deviendra
réel quand la pénurie de carburant
cessera-t-elle temps la chienlit
s'arrêtera-t-elle la parole est à
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président s'il vous
plaît il y faisait on écoute la réponse
vous le savez parfaitement la france a
déjà y'a pas si longtemps en 2010
étaient confrontés à une situation
identique
il y avait à l'époque à peu près deux
fois plus de stations en difficulté
pratiquement 5000 40% contre 20%
aujourd'hui et je n'aurais pas je
n'aurai pas la cruauté de rappeler la
teneur des questions d'actualité et des
réponses là où vous avez raison c'est de
demander au gouvernement
quelle est la réponse qu'il apporte à
cette situation il y avait deux
problèmes le premier concerné le
mouvement des chauffeurs routiers
j'ai adressé une lettre et vous pouvez
constater aujourd'hui que ce mouvement
qui est ce mouvement qui est à l'origine
des difficultés est aujourd'hui apaisé
parce que le gouvernement a maintenu le
dialogue
deuxièmement la question c'est la
question de la liberté d'accès aux
stocks et aujourd'hui le gouvernement
s'est engagé à libérer l'ensemble des
dépôts je partage votre appréciation
nous devons avoir la possibilité de
desservir les stations
tous les dépôts qui sont occupées par
d'autres personnes notamment que les
grévistes sont libérés ça a été le cas
ce matin ça a été le cas hier ce sera
encore le cas cet après midi donc
l'ensemble des camions disponibles
fonctionne et je veux simplement vous
dire à tous ceux qui nous écoutent que
on parle de pénurie mais que la vérité
qui s'était déjà d'ailleurs un peu vrai
aussi en en 2010 c'est que ces trois
derniers jours
nous avons aussi mais c'est un peu
normal probablement battu tous les
records de consommation c'est à dire que
nous sommes avec 500 % d'augmentation
dans certains secteurs
parce qu'il ya effectivement de la
précaution c'est ce que nous disent les
pétroliers qu'on a réuni ce matin
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
stabilisée et le gouvernement sur ces
deux objectifs
tian mort liberté d'accès au dépôt
liberté d'accès au dépôt pour desservir
l'ensemble des stations de service merci
monsieur le ministre
la pole est un monsieur